was his conclusion that high IQ
individuals generally have a slightly
higher RQ but in particular for certain
subtypes of RQ they're lower
yeah that's exactly it and but um but
even
you know and even amongst individuals
you know even amongst high IQ
individuals you'll have like enough
variation the RQ rationality is
something that we should be measuring
and then cultivating separately from IQ
in the other kind of academic uh
disciplines that we look at so he gives
the example of if you're recruiting you
know some recruiters do use IQ tests
still to kind of work out who's the best
person to employ but they're not really
measuring accurately rationality and you
want a rational Workforce really you
don't want someone who's gonna fall for
fake news uh fall for from some
kind of other company and make a bad
investment you want a rational Workforce
So He suggests that actually we should
be using the rationality question as a
means of selecting candidates and also
just as a means of identifying who could
do with some training like who needs to
learn more about maybe
how to read statistics or these to have
that awareness raised about things like
the sunk cost fallacy so they don't fall
for it in the future
is there a relationship between
high IQ and arrogance uh I wouldn't I
don't know if anyone's looked at it like
that because stanovic had looked at the
biased blind spot
um and that's essentially
you are someone like you tell them about
these cognitive biases and then you ask
them
do you think you're gonna suffer from
those Pisces yourself and what he found
was that people with the higher IQs
tended to think that they were less
susceptible than the other people
um they over exaggerated their
um
their resilience their protection
against the biases so they thought they
were much better than they actually were
and that was more likely the more
intelligent they were essentially so in
that you know in that sense I think the
bias blind spot is an example of
intellectual arrogance and it's a
serious problem because if you don't
have awareness of the ways that your
reasoning might uh fail then you're less
likely to try to account for that how
can an individual listening slash
watching this increase their RQ the
rationality quotient right so this is
still
um an area of research but I think like
there's very strong evidence that we can
improve elements of rationality